[Applaudissements]
mais on faire ça il s'empara mais qui
brille wave ou en fonte avec comme
encore trop générique j'ai vu ça j'ai le
temps de voir validée sans la 20h10 ce
soir j'ai un petit transat bien tu peux
de lecture zahera oui les amis on va
démarrer comme tous les jours avec les
24 heures tennis qu'il fallait voir
aujourd'hui mais très très très vite pas
si fou que je chope le dernier métro
c'est parti à faire conclut sophie
davant pose une question à laquelle jean
mi a forcément la réponse j'imagine
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau d'affaires conclut est ce que
vous savez ce que signifie dérouillée
non j'étais sur le mardi c'est sport où
tout le monde basses eaux de pluie tombe
bien l'examen
jusqu'au drame qui me maintient et là
tout simplement on va chercher à
développer sur ces news est championne
cas d'achat kabush il nous a prouvé que
cet ouvrier qui vient d'ouvrir un
myspace j'imagine lui aussi les cafards
c'est à dire google apple amazon apple
et [ __ ] ce qu'a voulu parler de
désintox au bout de deux essais après
faire lâcher à faire vendre ça ne suffit
pas à la 12e
un deuxième deuxième fois où ils sont
pris au bout de la troisième fois il va
te faire une cure de jeunesse
exclu voici les images de la belle kelly
en loge qui s'entraîne dur avant
l'émission pour être au top au monde et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ballon à dori ah ouais c'est bien je
sais bien thème bientôt j'adore
l'émission allemands ils font ça parce
que je viens d'un village dans les
halles de 600 habitants un tous les ans
les caméras d'm6 débarque dans la vie à
celle événement un candidat sur deux est
un pote de mon père tous les ans
vraiment et ça nous apprend plein de
choses pour ça que j'adore cette
émission c'est la solution qui met en
avant le paysage champêtre de l'hexagone
démission ou tu apprends que les la pop
en cash que les cochons mange des
graines et que les vaches se roulent des
grosses pelles comme jean miot papagayo
aussi l'occasion pour les agriculteurs
nous expliquer leur métier avec
gourmandise et poésie c'est comme ça
fait vite façon
merci à toi dans les nouveaux fonds
seront à découvrir chaque qui cherche
une femme distinguée qui se met sur son
31 mai il est pas une taille prénom le
kalalu week-ends murine top 5 on fait un
petit une petite sortie en ville n'a
qu'à se mettre sur son temps 2 samuel a
eu beaucoup de succès il faut dire hier
soir franchement à berck le gars pas mal
baroudé même gérard louvin il a pas
photo autre chose rires je me suis fan
de construction rénovation
après je fais du champ où j'ai planté
des arbres j'ai fait des courses
ailleurs jeunes du compost aussi une
fois je serai pour des marchés de fruits
et légumes
j'étais gardien de sécurité ouvrent le
feu de la pêche en mer dans les icebergs
et j'ai vécu en pleine forêt avec des
indices de terres que j'aurai un cargo
qui m'a surtout ça même quand tu y
réfléchis sans faire exprès il imite
jacques chirac c'est très rapide
regardez bien 3
la première avec l âge dix neuf ans et
karine a tout donné
nouvelle fois on aime beaucoup car henin
est dispo pour chaque candidat jean
clottes déjà c'est mon préféré c'est le
plus gentil franchement lui fait
laventure il n'est pas compliqué ce
qu'ils recherchent lui voilà il veut
pêchu et il a bien raison il proclama
des rondes
est-ce qu'on peut écrire tout peuple
métis pas d'un problème religieux ou pas
de problème moi j'aime mieux piller
messieurs le passé pied du 13h he has to
propre chics et blancs
[Rires]
peu après comme d'habitude caréna sorti
sa petite allusion co qu'il allait bien
que saccharides elle peut pas s'en
empêcher
voilà une fille si je suis bien avec
elle sera bien avec moi et qu'elle est
un brin d'humour calais ça je me prends
au caire voilà qu'elle était aussi faire
forcément les agriculteurs il se chauffe
à prendre l'entendent rigoler puissant
que karine a déchaîné 2000 à l'essai de
changer de coiffure une femme coquette
oui oui une femme coquette aura une
femme on ne peut faire des toits ont
voté femme qui a du style qui a du
talent de la classe contre six jeunes
karine si tu veux te voir tu m'oublieras
tout
thierry hot list
[Applaudissements]
et thierry on laisse ces bons d'efforts
oliva bon j'ai maté du sport au s'agir
d'un sort depuis deux jours tout le
monde parle de la victoire de lyon sur
le psg forcément ça fait parler grâce à
un but de memphis de paille facile à
dire quand on aime le foot j'ai bien le
foot un peu moins pour cette journaliste
de france 3 partout à la pause les
lyonnais enfonce coup à la fin du match
avec ce dernier but de l'office tu payes
désiré ans qui a parlé des attaquants du
real on doit sécher quelques cours de
français oui encore un peu de monde mais
sachez que le real va beaucoup mieux la
bbc belle ronaldo et un benzema va très
bien regardez ce qui s'est passé à
laurent paganelli l'avez loupé ça il
nous a montré qu'il a une logique
imparable or on l'a beaucoup
c'est logique et enfin on a été surpris
mais cocorico laurent voulzy et passe en
quarts de finale de l'open d'australie
bravo
c'est vrai qu'on me
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle joue bien oui ressemble à laurent
vous ce type au visionnement aussi admis
des notes et deux secondes vous en ai un
peu parlé mais je fais pas non plus par
les sports se rendirent sur l'événement
d'hier nicolas sarkozy invité dans
l'équipe du soir sur la chaîne l'équipe
nicolas sarkozy qu'on présente plus
puisque comme chacun sait c'est l'ancien
un beau-père de capucine agréable on a
retenu quelques trucs
déjà qu'il est hyper folie monsieur
sarkozy demande toujours s'il peut se
permettre de se permettre de se cramer
il voyait dans un miroir autorisation
permettait les critères disant si vous
permettez je n'ai pas tellement sur le
reste nous permet de le dire est le
nouveau projet si vous permettez à celui
où vous partager ce constat n'est quand
même pas je suis vraiment l'amateur au
milieu des professionnels du permettez
moi de vous dire que je ne nous permet
pas de m'insulter était tellement
content on a l'impression que c'était sa
première télé quand tu passes pour la
première fois la télé qu'est ce tu fais
tu passes un coucou en scred affecté
trois gardes près de penser que le grand
événement de football devait très peu
répartis entre la france l'italie pour
soir carla l'angleterre qui va moins en
allemagne le président et du coup il a
du mal à prendre son élan du journaliste
grégory schnyder mon selon m ok je cicig
rémission mais me permet de le dire
chaque d'eau éclaté c'était la soirée de
sa vie même quand le langage devient
plus corsé il est mort de rire de tout
soin de faire [ __ ] sale fils de [ __ ]
fruits
il est plus détendu on la retrouve et
détendue nicolas sarkozy on s'est
demandé ce que ça donnerait une
interview politique rapidement
aujourd'hui en avez vous eu le temps de
comprendre pourquoi vous avez perdu ce
jour-là mais on peut pas dire que les
circonstances ne sont pas là pour
expliquer les raisons d'une défaite en
plus à la dernière minute connaîtra tout
le nom de votre premier ministre ellison
cavani kitana n'ont toujours pas s'il
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'il va pas faire de la télé
peut-être nicolas sarkozy en le voyant
là je me dis qu'à mikami tu le sais pas
te croire son président que ouais ouais
ça de la télé franchement ça rapporte
plus de la passion aussitôt arrêté de
prendre l'argent julien un couloir grand
show politique ou à faire venir des ddd
d'autres présidents etc
raffarin je verrais bien un arnaud
camille le sens bien aussi comédies
musicales et sera énorme
franchement vous aussi peut-être pendant
trois manches de matthieu delormeau soir
ce week-end avait lieu l'élection de
miss top model belgique arrive par l'est
ou par non à chaque côté les américains
lui parler bah ouais donnent ils
s'intéressent modèle belgique qui comme
son nom l'indiqué avait lieu à paris 1
paris dakar plus ils soirée un très
showbiz avec de très belles femmes
regarder vraiment en allemagne était un
des plus belles mannequins top model de
belgique était présente avec un jury
d'exception dans une salle du lido qui
était pleine à craquer on a retenu la
candidate de son 31 qui est cédée
d'hypnotiser le jury
[Musique]
la descente en terre on a aussi mis la
miss qui avait pris ses talons une
pointure au dessus qu'il faut au retour
en une seconde
oui des alouettes sont très bons et
regardez bien le regard de la nuit
suivante qui la jugent tellement elle en
est l'aveu de sa gueule tu es foutu ma
lampe d'ailleurs d'une bourde
la salle était chauffée par quelqu'un
que vous dressez bien cyrille eric notre
chauffeur de salle
oui il était très en forme et autant
vous dire qu'il a vraiment mis le feu
non mais ces normes complète - font dans
la salle et toute la salle était à fond
annoncé
je suis toi salle d'arts ya une ambiance
de dingue vraiment ça bien bien bien
marché il un petit peu galéré surtout
quand ils annoncent des invités qui sont
pas là éric j'aimerais qu'on fasse un
peu d'établissements pour notre avis
rabais n'est pas là j'essaie de garder
les belles choses des choses que vous
avez donné une ensemble juste un peu
près de trois ans nous sommes jusqu'à
17h se marie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo mon chéri tu es formidable et
quelle élégance avec sur arrête je
voudrais faire autant un petit peu
autour de la table à jour très nombreux
sur cette vidéo la halle avec la me
rendis lui la suicide c'est pas possible
que je te ramener au comme ben hiba
moins cher et les incruster on s'est
accroché dans toutes les émissions télé
on est bien faire ça pour être chaud à
percy pour être sûr de rien raté vous
semblez directement à l'intérieur je
t'en supplie t une bonne personne pour
garder ce parti ses portes il est bien
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur et si 24
heures est couché avec jean guy debeyre
jean-guy d'autres éditorialistes
aujourd'hui salut pour l'instant je
place l'équipe de france en dessous des
nations l'allemagne comme l'espagne
qu'elle apprend on a simplement besoin
de l'expérience que les odes à nos
entrepreneurs non renouvelés et fait
vivre au quotidien par le dialogue de
nos cultures
[Applaudissements]
chose qu'ils aient baissé macro les
pythies ma croûte et je suis vidé la
france il est mignonne vous fait
rencontrer en fait c'est à la ciotat
on a flashé de suite puis s'il est
pressé il m'a dit qu'elle allait
m'offrir de couronnes b/j de dents
dévitalisées me fait mal bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui nouvelle épreuve dans fois
de suite bien plus difficile que ce que
vous avez connu vous allez devoir me
conjuguer le verbe à bois au présent de
l'indicatif
ça sert à rien de chalets jordan shipley
tu me fous un maillot
[Applaudissements]